foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions this is the Ramsey show where
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and build great relationships
I'm Ken Coleman I'm joined by Jade
warshaw the phone number is
88825-5225 that's triple eight eight two
five five two two five Jade's going to
be answering your money questions I'll
join in on that and I'm here to answer
any question related to work are you in
a job uh that you want to get out of but
you're afraid to because you're in debt
or you're in the baby steps in a toxic
environment trying to figure out what to
do do I go back to school anything work
related that allows you to make more
money I will take those questions on and
Jay jumps in onto those so we always
enjoy being together and and can I tease
that we have a little fun thing coming
up later in the program let's go Ken
tell them just just enough just just
keep them around we are going to talk
about the true difference between store
brands and generic brands with a taste
test there it is folks uh you don't want
to miss that it hits you right where
you're at your budget on groceries so
let's get it started again the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five we're gonna stay right
here in our backyard Nashville Tennessee
where Andrew is awaiting Andrew how can
we help
hey Ken hey Jade it's a pleasure to
speak to you all today you too
um so
it was a very basic question uh but it's
kind of a loaded question so do we owe
our kids
um do we owe it to our kids to pay for
their college no what is what is
Ramsey's what is y'all's
um Viewpoint you know for that because I
so I just let me frame the question real
quick not a long story uh this last
Monday me and my wife paid off our house
which was phenomenal wow
let's not just roll past that way to go
Andrew that's amazing that's amazing
yeah I appreciate that yeah we're
grateful to God for that uh but anyway
so we so you know when you have debt you
it's easy to focus where your money's
supposed to go but when you all of a
sudden you don't have debt it almost
feels like you're floating yeah um and
so I just want to make sure that I get
you know I got my investments I'm I'm
trying to get those in line but I want
to make sure you know I'm later in life
I'm 47 right now 47. and so I can't
afford to make any mistakes
um and so I'm just extremely cautious
and how many kids
uh two two
uh okay I mean I jumped in right away
and said no I want to point it out in
case you missed it yeah I look I agree
with that I just want to roll it back
just a little bit and kind of explain
that for people who are listening not
just you
um Andrew so obviously there is the baby
step five Right comes right after baby
step four which you're putting away 15
and then simultaneously you're putting
away 15 while you do that you have the
ability to fund a 529 or whatever you
know kids college account and at the
same time you have the ability to put
extra on your mortgage so four five and
six you do simultaneously
um but if you notice when it comes to
the baby steps baby step five is almost
one of the ones we talked the least
about it has the least um amount of uh
guidance around it you know everything
else is a very specific amount it's a
very specific thing and with baby step
five we don't ever say and when you do
your kids college you have to do this
amount right because it really is and
Ken can go into this in a minute it
really does depend on this child it
depends on their uh what profession
they're pursuing and you as a parent
I think that the bigger conversation is
is it a responsibility to pay for
college is it a responsibility to pay
for further knowledge like whatever that
is and then within that you can say okay
what would I like to do because as a
parent
I think that it is a privilege to be if
you were able to to fund some bit of
their further knowledge whatever that is
whether it's trades whether it's
education whether it's certificates
College traditional whatever that is I
do think as a parent it is I will not
say responsibility but I will say it's
something that we get the privilege to
do if we can and that does not mean 100
it does not mean 50 you get to decide
that as the parent
yeah I think the way you worded it if I
and correct me if I'm wrong the reason I
said no immediately is I think you said
do we owe them and there you go and so
when if did I get that right Andrew yes
sir I did say it that way I I don't know
if I really meant it that way but you
may not because you know the overall
social Norm is like you're a parent so
it the feeling a lot is that you you
have to pay for the college right so let
me tell you why I said no let me tell
you I said no
because it's just as good for you as it
is for someone else
so you don't owe them it's not your
responsibility you are responsible to
your kids
to provide them safety to ride them food
uh you know to provide them a Litany of
things that we all we don't have to go
through the list sure
um but you know I'm thinking of the
single mom
in a low income area
I would never say to you that it's your
responsibility to pay for your kids
school because I wouldn't say it to her
because that's an unfair burden to put
on her in the first place you know
people we've got to be honest here you
know people are in low-income situations
for a variety of reasons many times not
of their choosing but I can't tell you
how many Heroes there are in the form of
single moms who are in poverty
situations and just scraped everything
together
just to be able to food and clothe their
children right I am not about to say to
her that she has the added
responsibility to pay for higher
education that is absolute burdened and
it is it in now it's putting on this
this this unbelievable guilt if I don't
provide that so I know you didn't mean
it oh but you said oh and I think that's
coming from the feeling that you have
and if you're not in a financial
position
to where you can do it you should not
then feel guilty to try to figure a way
around it they can work to pay for their
own School uh let me also say this
because Jade set me up but I just want
to point this out part of what's going
on with this feeling you have is that
most American parents most
believe that their kids should go to
college because that's been the cultural
message you're not a good parent Jade if
you don't send Junior that's easy yeah
to school so let me just point this out
at some point we've got to be
intellectually honest with ourselves and
say what does my kid actually want to do
with their life if I get out of their
hair and I don't put all this pressure
on them and we step away from the
cultural pressure and I would say if we
figure out what they want to do I think
that is your responsibility I think you
have a responsibility to help your kid
figure out their Direction help is the
key word not decide and then I would
tell you that if College isn't the only
way or the best way
otherwise there's another way that's a
whole lot less affordable and a lot less
time consuming so I would tell you my
friend you need to do what's right for
you and your wife and your financial
future they got more time conceivably
than you do and so I want you to be set
free from that burden because that's
what it feels like on you and let me add
a two cents on there Andrew because what
Ken said is absolutely right you don't
oh you know you don't owe that like it's
my it's my responsibility to pay for
their school but it is your
responsibility to set clear expectations
absolutely and let them know hey if
you're pursuing whatever your form of
further knowledge is here's what we will
and will not do have those conversations
so they know going in hey if you decide
to go to trade school here's what we
will do here's what we won't do tell
them ahead of time so it doesn't get
down to the wire and it's like well wait
a second I thought you were supposed to
you know fund four years at Columbia you
know don't don't let them get that far
down the line and by the way for for
Andrew hang on I want to give you uh
student assessment to get clear
assessment the student version and for
any parent out there you can help your
teenager figure out their future it's
called the get clear studentassessment
ramseysolutions.com we'll be right back
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
backed by their 100 percent satisfaction
guarantee and shipping is always free
see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
rules and restrictions May apply
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined this hour by my
colleague Jade warshaw and friend Ken I
know I need to you really don't like the
colleague I mean you want everybody to
know that we're friends okay Mike but
you know what though when people say my
dear friend sometimes I always go are we
my good buddy my acquaintance we're
Beyond acquaintance oh no no we're
actually friends yeah but I'm saying
when you see that like in public public
figures go my dear friends my good
friends I'm not sure that your dear
friend yeah we're good you just want
people to know that you know them yeah
but in this case Jade and I are friends
and so we are thrilled to be with you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the phone number to jump in the
Ramsey Show question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services neighborly is the
place to find Reliable help for your
home entrusted locally owned businesses
like Glass Doctor Precision garage door
service and Mr Handyman visit
neighborly.com today to find home
experts available to serve you yeah
today's question comes from Philip in
Kentucky he says I'm a student at
University of Kentucky studying to earn
my Bachelor's of Science and electrical
engineering very cool my question for
you is as a full-time college student
what are some ways I can earn money to
support myself I doubt I will be able to
fit a job into my schedule and
scholarships have paid almost everything
I'm not looking for a quick fix but
rather a learning opportunity I'm very
conservative money-wise and only spend
money where I need to and I save the
rest if you have any tips or advice I
would greatly appreciate it well you
came to the right place Philip I love
what you said and I'll point out that
what you said is why I'm giving you this
answer you're not looking for money
um you want a learning opportunity so if
I were you I'd be using the proximity
principle that's why I wrote that book
you want to be around people who are
doing what you want to do and so I would
be looking for uh any type of work you
can do for somebody in that space of
electrical engineering so you know what
that space is far better than I but I'd
be working for an electrical engineer
even if it's five hours a week 10 hours
a week uh even if they wouldn't even pay
but you're like I just want to hang
around and learn from you because
money's not the object here yeah I want
you full-on proximity principle which
says in order to do what I want to do I
got to be around people that are doing
it and in places where it is happening
that's where opportunity knocks on the
door the fact that you're getting a a
major in that I would absolutely be
working as much as I could shadowing if
there's no money and my friend you watch
opportunities open up for you so I love
the question Jim very mature question
very very good yeah I'll leave it at
that that's good there it is let's go
now to the phones Omaha Nebraska is
where Ellen joins us Ellen how can we
help
hi guys I'm so excited that I got
through thank you for taking my call you
bet what's going on today
I kind of have a twofold question
um so one is career and one is what to
do
um with the debt I have on my vehicle
luckily that's the only debt that I have
great
um and that's twenty thousand dollars is
what I owe still on my car but that's
with interest I'm not sure what it is
without interest but I definitely feel
like I need to call and find that out
which is something I learned from the
show that's right
um
my payment is 455 a month okay what's
the car worth you know
um it's it's still worth about what I
paid for it I think which is 35.
Jay so you're saying that you owe 20 000
but if you sold it you'd get 35
I I think I could if I if I sold it on
my own like without trading it in for
something else yeah that's the only way
you're gonna get that value
is you sell it yourself which is what
I'm recommending I just wanna I I it's
rare that we get to where you're making
that much money I just want to make sure
those numbers are right
you owe 20 and it's worth 35.
sweet yes okay great um well I want to
know about your in I I got so excited
because usually folks are upside down so
it rarely it rarely goes in the
direction where you could make 15 grand
so that's excellent
um I want to know more about your income
this is your only car it's your only
vehicle uh what's your income
well when I bought the vehicle at the
time I'm
child of why you don't get yourself into
debt with your vehicle based on your
income
um so at that time when I bought this I
was projected to be making about 75 000
per year and then that full-time
position that I was in kind of got
pulled out from under me so now I'm just
doing my side hustle which is
um I'm in a partnership with the Airbnb
management company so which is great
part-time money like side hustle money
but it is not great what is it money so
um I'm making about 13 to 1500 a month
okay and what were you doing before what
was the full-time job that got pulled
out from underneath of you
it was still within the airbnbs but it
was
um
it was we were kind of running like a
mini hotel at the time so I was making
probably six to seven thousand a month
and then wow
yeah yeah so you're making you're making
six and a half thousand dollars a month
and now you're making on a good month
1500 a month
um when when is this Gonna Change like
when are you gonna get back into a
full-time job if you had to project
today like Jade I'm gonna be working by
this time next month I'll be working
again like what's what do you project
that to be
that's the other hard thing I've been
looking for about four months is when
this happened
um I've been looking and I've put in
probably 60 to 70 applications
um but I'm looking for a job that will
sustain me and my kids so I'm a single
mom and right now luckily I'm able to
live with my parents okay I was gonna
say how have you been living for these
months okay so you're with the parents
so really you're only the only thing
you've been paying for is the car and
I'm guessing food
no other no because there's no other
debt right
yep and then um my son is in private
school but he also has scholarships for
that so all right so yeah we got about
three minutes left and I want to get to
your work question so on the car let's
wrap that up I think I know what Jay's
gonna tell you yeah I mean it's been a
long time you've been working looking
for a job you can't continue like this I
would sell that car because for you to
pocket fifteen thousand dollars right
now would be huge then you can take some
of that money you know five or six
thousand and buy a car in cash something
that's going to be reliable for you
maybe it's eight thousand dollars either
way I want you to come out of this with
a decent amount of cash to your name um
do you have any other money saved
I did so I was really working my baby
steps and I had three thousand dollars
saved and that has that's gone and gone
now which I'm grateful that I had it
yeah that was what's been sustaining me
so okay so yes selling the car putting
aside a little bit to buy a reliable car
in cash putting the rest in the h y YSA
high yield savings account try not to
touch it okay and then Ken's gonna help
you with the career stuff because we
can't keep operating like this at the
very least you've got to get something
that's full time even if it's not the
dream job because you got to get money
coming in or else you're gonna blow
through that money that you just got on
the car in two seconds yeah what have
you been thinking about
because I know you've been applying but
but we can't just apply we've got to be
connecting with people who who know
about open jobs that can put a good word
in from you that's the first piece of
advice but in the limited time I've got
with you what are you thinking about
what what what what is that Forward
Thinking the type of work you want to do
um the stuff that I've been looking for
is like administrative bookkeeping that
type of stuff
um and I just I've been networking it's
just not the doors are closing and
closing that's okay listen I know that's
discouraging but that's what you want to
do something more clerical something
with numbers administrative work that's
your jam
okay great so you can't you can't quit
on this you have to keep talking and
connecting but to Jade's point she's
spot on right now I'm okay with you go
getting a 40-hour job that's paying you
20 bucks an hour even if it's a big box
store because it's going to give you
some momentum it's going to give you
more stability we wipe out the debt I'd
like to see you buy a seven to ten
thousand dollar Car Max and the rest of
that's in savings I'd stay with Mom and
Dad I think that's a blessing right now
I'd stay there until you get on your
feet but part of you getting on your
feet is just bringing in more steady
income 40 hours a week
and then we keep the networking we keep
connecting and then we eventually step
into that job that you're really looking
for so in this in this zone right now
where you're like I keep getting
rejected
um you keep going but let's go get
something that's just sitting there
right now in Omaha Nebraska that needs
somebody like you who can come in to do
a good job let's get 40 hours and and
move through the baby steps but I'd sell
that car today get it done buy another
car and you're gonna be fine single mama
uh you're a mama bear nobody's gonna
stop you so we're rooting for you so
hang in there uh hang on the line let's
give her uh the assessment to get clear
career assessment along with the book
from paycheck to purpose it's gonna walk
with you through this process thank you
so much Ellen for the call this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
foreign
welcome back America you are joining the
conversation about your life here on the
Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman Jade warshaw
with me as well the phone number for you
is free it's triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five Jade will take
your money questions I'll take your work
related questions they all have a way of
working together anyway and uh we're
here for you this is a safe place you're
not going to get chewed out and uh well
yeah I think you might choose somebody
else look a little bit I'm feeling
froggy let's see all right we'll see
I'll speak for myself uh maybe some
tough love but mostly love because we
want to help you win triple eight eight
two five five two two five Brandon is
now on the line in Atlanta Georgia
Brandon how can we help
hey uh how you guys doing today we're
having a blast what's going on
all right so uh took financial peace to
my fiance last year
um able to work through that over the
last year
um with really our only best band that
truck had purchased last year uh we got
that paid off last month
and we're getting married next month and
that is all being cash flow sweet though
no debt whatsoever she's had no student
loan debt
um so we are completely debt free there
now moving on to we're looking to
purchase a house next year once the
lease in our apartment in and we're
starting the process of uh saving it for
that down payment now my question would
be do we approach this like it's baby
step two where we pause any uh events in
retirement and throw it all at a down
payment or can we do both
that's a good question
um when it comes to that uh what you're
talking about is baby step three and
baby step 3B and investing do you
already have three to six months saved
I do okay so baby step three is done so
now it's a question between baby step
three B and baby step four investing the
15 and when it comes to that you can do
them both at the same time if you want
or if it's going to take you
um if saving for the down payment was
going to take you any longer than like
two or three years I'd be like no do not
wait like start investing at the same
time because I wouldn't want you to lose
that time like if it's going to be like
a three or four year process
um in your case if you did not move to
baby step four how long would it take
you to save for the down payment be
ready for earnest money closing costs
all that stuff how long would it take
uh I anticipate
seven nine months Okay then if I were
you and you guys are ready to go after
it I would do baby step 3B do the home
and then move on to baby step four so
you can just focus on one thing at a
time okay I don't disagree any questions
to that at all
uh no I don't believe so I I just
thought about doing ahead and funding a
Roth
um and then pursuing the down payment I
mean you can there's nothing wrong if
you're like hey I'm so excited to invest
I can't wait then yeah do both at the
same time but at the end of the day it's
really up to how quickly you and your
fiance want to accomplish this home
purchase and I always say Ken because we
we always talk about the down payment
you know and you want to get up to 20 if
you can no less than five percent but
there's a lot of cost that goes into
purchasing a home beyond the down
payment no question I mean I didn't know
I'm just being honest I didn't know the
first time Sam and I bought a house I'm
so glad that we had some extra money
laying around because I was like oh oh
yeah you you find the house you like you
put the offer in you sometimes you have
to put earnest money down and that can
be you know one to three percent sure
and then if there's closing costs that
are not baked into your you know loan
it's like you have to pay those and it's
like oh wait a second another ten
thousand dollars you know you don't know
so I would I would always advise people
I always say come in with a stack deck
that's your down payment D earnest money
e and closing costs C make sure you know
that going in what it is so you don't
get caught you know what I'm saying and
and Brandon I I think Jay's absolutely
right and I would throw one other thing
on top of that and that is I'd have some
I'd have some uh oh I'm a homeowner cash
set aside because I've got a real story
for you Jade let's hear uh the house
that we're in now you get you and Sam
were over that front room of ours the
the library room well you you know we
wanted to turn that from a dining room
into a into a library we just bought
this house and so we did all the things
you're talking about so you get in yes
good inspection yes no problems on the
inspection which that costs two five
seven hundred bucks it does so we get in
and we go all right we're gonna put some
shelves nothing extravagant just some
shelves so what we had to do is we had
to pull the chair rail off yeah and in
doing so we we noticed the drywall I
mean it was a little squishy oh yeah
long story extremely short
who knows how many years there had been
uh there wasn't proper flashing on the
outside of the brick wall on the outside
and and when it had a strong rain yeah
and there was mold in there and
everything so we ended up having to
spend
thousands and thousands of dollars just
by trying to hang a shelf just by a
basic let's put some custom bookshelves
in there so all that to say we had the
cash yes uh and and but it cost way more
than we planned that's right and we had
to do some real maneuvering uh and we
had to delay some of it once we got the
we got the mold out and we fixed the
water so it was no longer an issue so
just to point out when you buy that
first house you never know what's going
to happen and so Brandon it's not in any
way to discourage you but I would tell
you
uh if you can wait wait I'd like every
couple to just wait just a little bit
longer so you're not cash poor when you
actually move in the house yeah because
when you say wait you're saying stack up
as much money as you possibly can yeah
don't just take a down payment to your
point but I'm also going I want to have
you know we tell people to pause the
baby steps for the baby coming yes
because you don't know what's gonna
happen I'd say the same thing for the
house I'd say
let's let's have some cash so you're
moving this new house if something has
to be fixed I'm not talking about Reno
the bathroom the way you wanted it and
you're not so you're saying so make it
to where you're not having to dip into
your emergency funds simply because you
just got like it's not an emergency that
you need a U-Haul truck right it's not
an emergency that you need to get the
home inspected yeah it's not an
emergency that you need you know all
these things would have some extra cash
for those first three or four months
because that's when you discover stuff
and of course it can happen at any time
oh yeah but I just most people don't
think that they go okay get the down
payment get this and now I'm in can I
tell you you told the story when we
first our second house that we got we
moved in and we did a Renault on the
kitchen before we even moved in because
the kitchen was crazy and uh got in we
were in there like two nights and our
bedroom was upstairs we're like upstairs
for the night like ready to go to bed
and light lights off at one point Sam's
like I need to do like what is that
sound and we heard something we didn't
know what it was we go downstairs years
the on the valve underneath the kitchen
sink had like busted water was pouring
in oh my God pouring thank God for his
ears I mean we would have been asleep I
don't even know how we heard it I
wouldn't have heard it it was flooding
so quickly and I was like oh my God I
mean it was enough to wear like we had
to stop everything we had to call the
air air serve pro you know what I'm
talking about to come and make sure
everything was dry do you understand if
we had gone to sleep and not heard that
we would have woken up yeah oh
did he did he go turn the water off
outside we had to turn it off outside by
the way that's one of the most valuable
things new homeowners that my
father-in-law taught me find out where
your master water shut off is before you
ever get the keys to the new house go oh
where's this where is it because that
that's a lifesaver if you know where
that baby is yeah he had to go turn it
off and let me just say water and home
are two those are two words you never
want going together how bad you you
still you got a little trauma because
I'm like if we had not what if we had
already fallen asleep we would have
woken up to a pool downstairs yeah you'd
have to replace everything downstairs
oh God is good yes you've been there
done that I'm not going to go to one
more story but it is important that when
you get into a home that you because so
many people want to rush into a home and
you end up being house poor oh it's
terrible you can't actually afford to
live in the house and that filters into
everything Ken when your house poor it
filters into how you work and how you
show up at work oh because you're
realizing in that moment it's like the
only reason that I'm working is to pay
this bill right and I'm not even there a
lot because I'm at work 40 60 hours a
week true you know this is a home should
be a place of Peace yeah
um and if your home is a place to stress
just because of the finances I'm telling
you that dream turns into a nightmare
quickly so hey here's here's what we're
saying having we we've been there done
that your older cousins here talking to
you
don't rush into a house
be able to afford the house and and what
comes with it it's going to be a whole
lot better situation but if you didn't
and you're in some trouble Jade and I
are here to help we can help you get out
of it it's okay we've all dug out of
stupid before you're not the first you
won't be the last don't move more of
your calls coming up this is the Ramsey
Show
foreign
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than thirty
four thousand customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up up
their operations to learn more get a
free product tour at netsuite.com Ramsay
that's netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by my friend Jade warshaw
and we're here for you triple eight
eight two five five two two five hey if
you're new to the show and we know a lot
of you are it's so exciting Jade when we
sit in these meetings they give us
updates yeah and then we're getting a
lot of calls I mean we were on just a
couple days ago hey I just started
listening two weeks ago so a lot of
brand new listeners and viewers and we
want to say number one welcome number
two we know there's some lingo around
all this money stuff and so when you
start thinking about the process and you
maybe you're new and you're picking up
on some of these phrases and baby steps
and what does that mean we the team has
done a great job we've got to get
started assessment it's just a couple of
minutes at ramseysolutions.com it's
under the get started button and with
just a couple of questions about your
financial situation uh we'll be able to
get you caught up as to where you are in
the journey and now you feel like okay I
get it I see where I am and where I'm
headed so check that out the get started
button at ramsesolutions.com
Alma is up in Orlando Florida dama how
can we help
hi
um so uh my husband and I recently moved
from Illinois to Florida to help my
parents we pay half of their expenses
their elderly in the move I sold my
house
and
um saved about 45 000 and put in a CD in
the event we decide to purchase a home
um but the only thing I have
left to pay for debt is my student loans
and I was wondering if I should just use
the money that I have in the CD and some
savings that I have
um accumulated since moving here to
throw it at the student loan and and
take care of that first for moving like
even thinking about moving into a new
house or buying a new house or what yeah
how much is a student loan for
it's about uh 78 000 so 78 77 something
but we'll round it up for 78. okay and
so you've got the 45 000 in a CD and
then I think you mentioned you had some
other money saved as well
yeah I have about a thousand dollars
saved in the flexible savings account
like a high interest okay savings
account so a thousand dollars there
anything else
um no I do have like a 529 plan that for
my daughter's college and we won't touch
that I do have a Roth IRA okay and we
won't touch that either so we wouldn't
touch the college fund or the retirement
and just just for clarity did I hear you
say we moved is that you is it you and
your husband
Jeffrey yeah my husband and I okay your
husband
um okay sorry I'm digging deep on this
I'm digging a little bit deep Dharma
um
you said your student loan and I've
heard you say like my I've got this
saved I just want to be clear does your
husband have any debt or is it just your
yours
uh no actually I paid off all of his
debt that um he had he had we just we
just got married last year okay so and
so part of the proceeds from the sale of
the house I used to eliminate his debt
and also a car loan and so the the
leftover money
um after like the expense of moving I
put in CD because I didn't want to touch
that I see okay so to answer your first
question yeah I would I would clear out
all debt before buying a house so I
would um use I would keep the thousand
dollars that you have I'd keep that set
aside but effectively you're in what we
call baby step two which is when you're
paying off all of your debt except your
mortgage and so you keep the thousand
dollars saved as a starter emergency
fund and then in your case you would
clear out that forty five thousand
dollars put it towards a student loan
debt and then with your income and your
husband's income I want you both working
together to clear the rest of the
student loan debt that's going to remain
the other thirty thousand or whatever
does that make sense and you're doing
that as quickly as possible then you're
both working together to save up your
down payment somewhere between five and
twenty percent does that work for you
yeah it's it's a bit scary but yeah well
yeah and let's talk about that it is
scary you've got this forty five
thousand set aside you know it was
probably a little bit easier when you
were putting money towards your
husband's portion of the debt because
you knew you had this Nest Egg you know
forty five thousand that's you know
that's a little bag to keep to the side
and now the idea of dropping that down
to a thousand dollars feels shaky right
and it should you know there's validity
there it should feel like oh my gosh
like this is crazy but the hope is that
you're going to use that as fuel to move
quickly right you're quickly paying off
this debt and then the next part of this
Dome is you've got to save up three to
six months of expenses
because I don't want you to go into Home
Ownership with no savings that's going
to be I mean Ken and I were talking
about it earlier that's gonna that's a
recipe for a disaster so you do have a
little bit of a journey in front of you
but it's a good journey because it's
going to set you up on the right footing
so that when you purchase this home
you're going to be like
deep breath yeah it's gonna feel great
so when I hear you what I hear you
saying is to throw all the money that I
have saved in CD and the savings into
the student loans pay that off once I
that paid off then I work on the three
to six month expenses after that then I
work on saving for a down payment that's
right right here that's right just make
sure you keep just make sure you keep a
thousand dollars set aside because I
want you to have some you know little
cushion money in case you have an extra
month you know an emergency I want you
to have a little money there so keep
that thousand that you had saved and
then everything up everything else goes
to that debt yeah got it you got it you
got it yes Doma and she's really gonna
do it she you know she is she's gonna do
it we hear some people and you go
they're not gonna do it we just told
them to do no she's someone's gonna do
it she's like I get it give me the game
plan and I'm running
yeah because you always have conflicting
information about students don't loan
debt you're like oh you're never going
to pay that off why would you ever throw
extra money at that yeah
and um that's where I was just like do I
do it or not but yeah you absolutely
want it anymore
forever yes that's it look the folks
telling you don't pay it you know you'll
never be able to get those are people
who have lack of confidence in what they
can do and they're projecting that onto
the masses I'm like no y'all don't put
that evil on me Ricky Bobby y'all y'all
keep that over there for me and mine we
can do this shake it shake it you knew I
was going there
uh she's on a roll I think you can help
Austin in about two and a half that's
good let's go Austin Jade is standing by
what can we do for you
uh
first time calling a long time listener
oh I love it me and my wife we are
in about 65 000 in total debt we got
probably 12 000 student loans uh another
10 and credit cards but we also have two
cars and my car and we got about 8 000
our car we got 24
000 but it's only worth 21 now because
she's done so much driving last year for
her previous job is it Elise
uh no we uh we just thought we have it
through Finance okay and uh so
we
over the last probably a year and a half
because we started the baby stuff
uh first off uh January of last year
kind of like a New Year's resolution and
we have paid off
probably close to 75 000 in debt that's
great
we kind of hit a log Jam okay so we're
trying to
figure out the best ways to
get that out of there what's the Log Jam
I'm gonna move you around move you along
a little bit so we can get to the end of
the call but what do you think the Log
Jam is because you were moving along
good we're we're not finding extra money
to pay off extra debt did you guys
change your did you change your working
situation did somebody switch jobs or my
wife my wife switched jobs she went from
making probably close to 80 now she's
down to 40. well there's there's your
Little Gym my friend we need more
Revenue so let me let me give you the
feature yeah let me give you the quick
answer because here's what we know when
she was making forty thousand more you
guys were moving right along now that
that 40 000 is gone you're not so it's a
it's an easy it's an easy equation but
it's a hard equation right we know where
the problem is right we know it's income
so right now y'all have gotta work to
get that income back up as close to that
forty thousand as possible so you can
move right along and in the meantime
yeah I'm looking at these cars if you
want to move faster you could if it's
worth 21 you could take the three
thousand dollar hit right go down to
your local credit union and get that
loan and then put a few thousand dollars
with it and buy a car in cash and you'd
be out of the twenty four thousand
yeah you can do this this is about doing
whatever it takes to get more money in
to get through this season thank you so
much for the call all right that does it
for this hour
don't move more Ramsey show coming up
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions this is the Ramsey Show it's
where we help you win in your life
specifically your money your work and
your relationships I'm Ken Coleman Jade
warshaw joins me the phone number for
you to jump in is triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
it's your show cause it's your life and
we're here to help so let's go Albany
New York well this is great if my eyes
don't deceive me this is one of my
favorite things is it's alliteration yes
uh this is Alba from Albany I mean this
is like a gift to a broadcaster say I'm
saying it right is it Albert or Alba
I can work with that
but I got a better one it's Alba from
Albany who's from Albania who lives in
Albany from Albania you're from Albania
yes
I just want to make sure everybody
catches this we're talking to Alba who's
from Albania but now lives in Albany
this is very exciting this is a
broadcaster's dream come true it's
driving James the producer nuts so we'll
get into the call how can we help okay
okay so
um I've got a home equity loan that we
took out and as well as Mortgage Debt
and
um we're at one income household with
two kids so my husband makes about
um like 60 Grand take home at the end of
the year and I was wondering if we have
a 401k and I was and I was wondering
should we take out money out of our 401K
which includes like a nine percent
interest on whatever we take out to pay
off a home equity line of credit no no
no no no back to ourselves no
no because you're you're trying to solve
debt with debt
you can't solve a problem while
simultaneously creating a problem and
you're taking one loan to try to you
know it's like that robbing Peter to pay
Paul right so the only way to pay off
debt is to pay off debt with real money
that wasn't allotted for something else
right and you're not going into debt to
do that so let's break this down let's
figure out how we're going to do this
how much is the home equity loan
it's right now 46 Grand okay 46k and the
income is sixty thousand dollars you got
two kids at home
yes and this is the only debt or is
there other debt
yeah and we also have our mortgage debt
and that's all okay and that's fine so
baby step two we're paying off all the
debt except the mortgage and so I would
lump this into baby step two but which
by the way though let me just double
check your mortgage how much is it like
what's the full amount you owe 115 115
000. interesting
so technically Ken what we would say is
if the HELOC is more than 50 of the home
value then we would lump it in with
paying off the home if it's less then
we'd add it to baby step two so in this
case
technically you could lump it in with
paying off your do you guys have an
emergency fund
I think you're right I think you're
right Jade I think we put that into the
home and let's let's tackle the uh baby
step three but here's here's here's why
I'm very nervous about this because of
what
I had to do earlier
lets me know that you're not necessarily
done with debt yeah and can we explain
that did you let me just ask you this
Albert do you understand why we don't
want you borrowing from your 401k
um my husband did mention something
about you know leaving money in there
because of the in stock and stuff like
that well like you know Jade explain why
I want you to understand this because if
you understand this you won't touch it
you you will never even think about it
again so number one I'm a baby
then I will well let's talk about it so
with your 401 NK Alba the purpose of it
it's for retirement and so when you
touch that money before 59 and a half
before retirement age there's penalties
on it that's number one so if you guys
pull out a certain fifty thousand
dollars to pay this off you're going to
be penalized for that and I think at
this point it's 10 something like that
so you're gonna have to pay that then
you're hit with the taxes of it because
it's adding to your income so you would
have to pay taxes on that money then
there's this whole idea of like if you
have a 401k loan if something were to
happen and your husband were to lose his
job he's on the hook for that money
right because it's part of his 401k so I
believe he's got a calendar year I think
he's got a year to pay that until he's
hit with more penalties and fees so it
puts you in such a precarious situation
I would never again and at the Crux of
this whole argument is the idea of
you're not really solving the problem of
debt you're just shifting it from one
very important asset which would be your
home to another very important asset
which would be your retirement account
and that that uh line of thinking just
doesn't make any sense what you really
want is you if you ask yourself what do
I want here I don't want to feel the
weight of this HELOC anymore that's
really what you're after in Your Heart
Right is you don't want to feel this
debt it's on your home so the solution
to that really is to pay it off with
your own hard-earned money and that way
when it's gone it's gone it's not just
shifted over here and shoved in the
closet over there right I'm curious how
much money do you think you and hubs can
throw at this right now without doing
anything different than what's happening
today how much extra could you put on it
right now
um well not nothing really I mean we've
got
Seven Grand in our checking and we don't
even have like we've got 200 on our
sanding okay okay so the way I look at
things like this Alba is if I were gonna
pay it off in a year that would be about
four thousand dollars a month we would
have to put towards the home equity line
okay and if we can't do that then we say
okay you start well could we do two
thousand a month and so you begin to be
able to picture this you've got to have
an end in mind or else it just feels
like this this mountain we can never
climb so we've got to start to put some
goals and we say okay if we pay it off
in a year we would have to do this if we
paid it off in two years we'd have to do
this I think that's really important for
you guys to look at and go okay what is
possible if we make some changes in our
life I'd start with that exercise but uh
Jade to you and I mean you're you
understand that you're the expert on
this one if they were to wrap it into
the mortgage and tackle it that way
after getting through baby step three
yeah because well either way to to get
that baby step three if you go that
route it's going to take you guys a
while you guys need more income you need
more income and less expenses right now
to make more momentum does that make
sense right yeah Ken is right on you
need more income coming in I want to ask
if you're on a budget
we are not so I've been telling my
husband we gotta sit down and do this
for real get a pen on paper yeah uh and
let's not do pen on paper
um matter of fact let's let Christian
pick up and let's get you guys into
every dollar and not only that so every
dollar is the budgeting app that we
created here at Ramsey Solutions it's
the only budgeting app I I use Alba my
husband and I used it to pay off over
460 000 of debt and not only that but
George Campbell one of our personalities
is going to be hosting a free webinar
September 26th and I want you to attend
that okay we're going to put the
information on the screen in the show
notes I want you to go to that and
Christian's going to pick up afterwards
I want him to hook you up uh use my my
promo code Okay Christian so she can get
15 off of every dollar because that's
what you need you have your own promo
codes come on everydollar.com Jade and
if you want to do the web the webinar
it's everydollar.com budgeting okay yeah
to take part in that George is going to
walk you through that webinar again
that's every dollar by the way
everybody's invited everydollar.com
budgeting thank you for the call we just
talked to Alba who's from Albania but
now lives in Albany this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
foreign
over your head with student loans and
tired of getting calls from collection
agencies if private student loan debt is
taking away your financial piece and you
don't see any way out you need why refi
they're not a debt settlement company
and they're not connected to a bank why
refi refinances defaulted private
student loans that other places won't
touch and gives you a custom loan built
for you based on your ability to pay so
when you refinance your private student
loan debt with why refi you'll have a
payment you can afford with a low fixed
interest rate you couldn't get anywhere
else to help you stick to your budget
and work the debt snowball and you can
save thousands of dollars to learn more
about this custom refinancing option and
a lump sum payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show where we
talk about your life specifically your
money your work in relationships Jade
warshaw is with me I'm Ken Coleman and
this segment is going to be about your
budget and specifically
groceries oh the biggest budget Buster I
mean we're in this season of it feels
like forever inflation and one of the
areas that hits people the most is
groceries that's right so tell people
first of all I'm I'm so excited uh this
is what I call sample time on the Ramsay
show oh heck yeah I I'm just an absolute
stooge right here and and Jade is going
to walk you through and walk me through
some sampling and you're going to prove
a point here I'm going to prove a point
the point is when especially when you're
in baby step two you're trying to save
money at the supermarket at the grocery
store you make sacrifices you know you
want to get Cheerios but instead you get
our value right or Great Value and so
we've got to make those sacrifices and
here's the thing we're really going to
taste and see if there's really a big
difference in the way it taste because
we know there's a big difference in the
price so Ken so what so I want it for
our listening audience what we've got
here is a round table on the desk yes
and here's what we're about ready to go
through we've got some coffee I can
smell coffee two Brands a national brand
and a much much cheaper brand all right
and then we've got some shredded wheat
looks like yep we've got the national
brand Kellogg's and then the store brand
all right and then we've got some basic
chips no flavor nope basic potato chips
we've got the national brand which is
Lay's right and then now I'm gonna
sample these yeah but no what's worrying
me James and Jade if I can be honest is
I see two rolls of toilet paper I ain't
sampling those no it's not ready for
that we'll put them through the test
though we'll put a test on them so Ken
let's try these chips because
that makes me laugh I like the nice
toilet paper so I can just tell you by
the looks uh we'll get to that what are
we doing first so everybody buys potato
chips you put them in the kids lunch you
can either spend 4.79 on an eight ounce
bag of lays or you can spend 289 on the
store brand so so give them a try so
which so I bring both bowls over here
well let me get some candy I didn't know
you were doing it what am I supposed to
do a chip all right one chip taste it
all right
this is a good one
I had to eat it on the mic that's what
makes it either entertaining or awful
it's awful for a lot of people okay
that's your standard chip that's right
there taste this one all right now hold
on I need to like
cleanse my palate okay hold on cleanse
your palate
okay A little sip here all right now
this is number two
oh that's some good uh that's good radio
right there did you hear the crunch that
was a great I'll tell you this it's an
obvious winner for me which one number
two number two is the
and and you know why I chose it taste
and crunch it's 1.90 9 deeper that's
almost two dollars
the first one was lays and they were
stale as heck weren't they what's the
other one Publix brand I'm going Publix
brand overlays wow wow wow wow wow and
part of a chip by the way for a guy I'm
speaking on behalf of all men so ladies
listen to this
part of eating chips for guys is the
sound
I want to hear a crunch
since you like the crunch now we're
going with cereal all right standard
standard Shredded Wheat right Kellogg's
by the way true story never had shredded
wheat in my life ever first time right
now and then we've got the store brand
so let's pour some milk in the cereal
for the people listening you're actually
doing milk I'm doing milk I've never had
milk in my I don't put milk in myself oh
that's not milk for our listening
audience that's oat milk well I have I
have to be able to try it two percent
man give me the lactose all right get
you a spoon can a spoon and taste one of
these folks I get paid to do this I
almost just want to point this out okay
this first time ever yeah I like
Shredded Wheat but I just eat it dry you
also like oat milk here we go
I didn't slurp did I no you didn't slurp
you could slurp it on the radio though
people like that
all right all right that's the first one
what's next okay use your same spoon and
try the second one because I want to try
this
all right all right how are we doing on
time James we're doing good our fearless
we're good we're good okay I'm gonna
taste this one too first of all no one
should ever eat anything with oat milk
let me just tell you that right now
I don't understand how if you got to be
healthy and this is what life is like
that's kind of good I don't want to live
it that's kind of good I like it I put
orange juice in my cereal okay clear
winner again what's the one first one
that's the story man I don't know what's
going on again apparently I am a generic
dude guys and by the way take it away
from this this is a blind taste test
only I know which one is the store brand
I have no clue it'll come as no surprise
to anybody okay so Ken what you're
saying is I'm telling a friend which is
a a dollar 88 cheaper again almost two
dollars difference is better tasting it
is is it because they're putting more
bad stuff in it
here's the thing most of these uh store
brands are made at the same manufacturer
as the national brand it's the same
thing they just slap a different label
on him well if it's the same thing why
do I keep picking the cheap brand I
don't know I think they taste I'm
telling you that the cheap chip tasted
different I'm saying it did it had the
crunch now let's try this this coffee
coffee is what we have here you guys
know of course it's better to brew it at
home than Starbucks but in this case is
this mine here yeah that's yours now I'm
gonna put a little creamer in my coffee
I'm gonna drink it black just because so
you can really get the taste because I
want to judge them okay okay yes I won't
do cream so the first one here first one
down the hatch is this gonna burn my
tongue so I can sue you do I get to sue
Dave if I burn my mouth
I'm kidding stop it that's gonna be on
social media later oh my gosh
taste it
okay all right okay golly oh that's nice
you people that drink coffee black and
act like you like it I want you all just
own it you're lying to me what are you
saying I like black coffee might as well
had a shoe bottom in there then that
means it's not good no all black coffee
is terrible no it's not see it's not a
manly thing I'm man enough to go I want
some sugar and cream in my coffee can I
oh man I have my choice all right number
two
that was off that was Dreadful okay this
one was this one
I'll put it
oh gosh yeah number two is even worse
than number one all right so on that one
here's what we did the national brand
was Pete so you guys have heard of
Pete's Coffee yeah and then the 5.99
brand was Cafe bustilo which is a Latin
brand which I like I thought that that
one was better because I like a full
bodied but guys which one's cheaper Cafe
bustilo it's five nights it's a cheaper
one no you chose the expensive one
because you're bougie kin but I chose
the less expensive one apparently I'm
not I mean it's a seven dollar
difference 6.60 all right so now we're
starting to in the budget here we're
gonna come back to this so maybe I
scrimp on the chips and I pay a little
more for the coffee I mean we're working
our way through this or maybe just put
creamer in the coffee oh
all right now there's a big one can
toilet paper I'll see I don't even have
to well I'm not sampling it so what am I
doing I mean I gotta touch it I'm
touching it Ching it it looks like it's
got a decent ply to it oh okay I can
hold
up my nose I don't have anything yeah
blow your nose let me let me just let me
just
okay come on Ken okay we're good James
well let's think about this the Charmin
for the same amount the Sherman 7.79.
okay and the Angel Soft
is this Angel it's 479 well I don't know
you told me don't be reading it just
look at it oh I didn't read hold on I
got to wipe my nose really quick okay
that is a three dollar difference guys
there's no question there's no question
uh the the second one is much softer on
my nostril it's softer but will the
first one get the job done Ken that's
the question when it comes to toilet
paper I don't want John Wayne toilet
paper you know what John Wayne toilet
paper is it's rough and it's tough and
it won't take crap off of it hey watch
out I'm going number two it's softer
what do you want to say I don't want you
to go number two anywhere in the studio
oh I walked right into that one all
right so which I chose uh toilet paper
you chose Charmin which is three dollars
more expensive I'm gonna pay three more
dollars for my bottom I'll be honest
with you I am team Angel Soft that's
what we bought when we were in baby step
two and look it's a short-term sacrifice
for a long-term gain you your bum will
be okay I tell you what I'm doing then
let's talk real budgeting real budgeting
what if I I go generic brand I save all
that money on everything else but I
spend on the soft double ply toilet
paper I say do what you got to do Ken
again we're making trade-offs this is
trades you know you can say hey I'm
willing to scrimp on this in order for
me to have a little bit extra to buy
that walk through this how much money
could we save if we go generic brand
across the board all the way up and down
the old list oh hundreds per month
hundreds there it is easily hundreds we
just now just right here we saved ten
dollars
more from you on this and budgeting and
everything else come on and go to my
Instagram boom she's doing Jade warshaw
that's where it's at yeah Ken this was
fun hey we save people some money
um I'll be honest with you though I
wouldn't scrimp on the toilet paper I'm
going premium team Angel Soft all day
give me my three dollars back oh oh can
you got bougie nostrils I do I do it's
been said many times hey good stuff
don't move we got more of your calls
coming up next I'm gonna eat some ships
[Music]
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow how is the number
one Prayer app in the world and they're
giving you three months free to get
started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow is
ethic you can tailor the content towards
your faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember Halo is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hallow.com Ramsay today and follow the
simple prompts to start your free 90-day
trial that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw joins me we're here
for you America taking your calls about
your money your work and your
relationships triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the phone
number eight eight two five five two two
five got a great crowd today in the
lobby and I want to just mention we got
a lot of new people listening and
watching all the time and if you ever
get to the Nashville area we'd love to
have you stop by you can watch the show
in the lobby would love to come out and
say hi to you we feed you free treats
and free hot beverages I mean I don't
know what else you could want uh so we'd
love to see you come by and see us
ramseysolutions.com to kind of check the
show schedule and all that jazz there as
well all right Talon is up in Little
Rock Arkansas Talon how can we help
hey how's it going good how are you
oh I'm I'm better than I deserve I've
heard that a time or two uh I like your
draw a little bit I like how you put a
little extras a little extra length on
that that was good how can we help
oh I'm I feel uh overwhelmed and we're
just a tower of debt oh tell me about
the tower build it for Jade please
absolutely
um the total debt is 36 271
um about
22 000 of that is in vehicles
and uh the other 15
is or almost 15 is between personal
loan and credit cards okay tell us about
the cars how much do you owe on them and
what are they worth
so that's the downfall a few years ago
um my life and me and my family were
traveling working I was working on the
road making a lot better money than I am
now and just gotten a bind and a lot of
vehicles that I couldn't afford and I
moved back had to give up the vehicles
and so one of them after they sold it
and however that whole scenario goes I
owe four thousand four hundred and
thirty six on one of them and then the
other one that
we let them repo we owe 17
684 on we do not own either one of those
Vehicles anymore oh wow what's the car
worth that that you owe 4400 on the only
one you have
I don't have that one he doesn't have
either of them I'm confused what did I
miss you have zero cars
well I have I have two vehicles both of
them are paid off I paid cash for them
whenever I got rid of those vehicles and
so I let both of those go back okay
so the two vehicles you have that are
paid off what are those both worth
um my wife she does a Camry it's
probably seven thousand and then mine
isn't maybe five hundred dollars that's
260 000 miles on it okay okay so and
then uh Tommy Talon what's your what's
your income
I make forty seven thousand a year uh my
life doesn't work right now what do you
do for a living
oh I'm a police officer
and uh why is your wife not working
uh she was at home with the kids my son
just turned six and just started
kindergarten and my daughter's in
therapy and so this just be going and
we're trying to figure out what what
she's going to do for work okay so
that's a big key Point how your daughter
that's in therapy how old is she
he's four and a half four and a half
okay so with the other kid going to
daycare we do want to or going to
kindergarten we do want to think about
your wife working even if it's part time
something that she can do to bring in
money I'm gonna let Ken tackle that
career stuff because at the end of the
day I would like to see you guys get
your income up I mean you're definitely
below the national average and I'd like
to at least get you up to the national
average uh in the 60s okay so that's the
goal for now
um and until we can get extra margin in
the equation you don't have a lot of
wiggle room right so you've got this uh
almost thirty seven thousand dollars of
debt uh are you guys working on a budget
uh no not enough to say we are okay so
that's thing one the first thing I want
you to do when you leave this phone call
is I want you to go to everydollar.com
and I want you to download a free
version of every dollar it's our
budgeting app and it's gonna you're
gonna do a zero based budget so you're
gonna put in your income and you're
gonna subtract all the things that you
spend money on those things that stay
the same every month like your your
mortgage your car payment you know those
things and the things that have the
ability to change like your groceries
your gas money I want you to think of
everything that you could possibly spend
and it's going to do all the math for
you okay and it's going to tell you how
much you have left and it'll either be a
number in the green saying hey not only
can you pay all your bills but you've
also got a little bit of money left over
or it's going to be in the red because
you mentioned that you have some credit
cards are you still using the credit
cards
nope we've cut them up don't have any of
those anymore
um nothing excellent and is there any
money saved anywhere
no okay no not at all so the goal is
we're gonna get get off the phone we're
downloading every dollar we're working
through that budget like I said and then
the first thing out of here is as
quickly as you can sell whatever you can
I want you to get a thousand dollars set
aside because if you have a thousand
dollar set aside Talent
hear me when I say you are going to be
ahead of the majority of Americans
because most Americans don't it doesn't
matter how much they make at work most
Americans don't even have a thousand
dollars
and could not cover a thousand dollar
emergency so you're gonna do that and
you're going to feel you're gonna be
able to hike up your pants and be like
all right I'm doing something good I'm
already ahead and then we're gonna start
tackling this debt Ken hit him with the
advice yeah so before we get into ideas
I'm just I want you to to get some
ownership out of this Talent if I said
um hey you've got to come up with twenty
thousand dollars in the next two to
three months
um you gotta work it you gotta work for
it
what are the first couple of ideas that
would hit you if you had to come up with
that kind of money
so working for the police department we
have what we call off duty stuff which
is where businesses and stuff contract
work out to our police department and we
do that yeah
um I I currently work normal 84 hours
every two weeks
um over the next 32 days I'm working 29
days we have off duty it pays 50 an hour
um so I'm able to hear in the next month
I'm going to be able to make about an
extra six grand and all that's going to
go towards it that's huge what else
could you do what else could you do it
doesn't even have to be tied to your
police work I love the overtime as it
relates to uh you know parking cars at
churches or directing traffic not
parking cars but I love that you got to
get more like like I I'd like you to get
even more of that because you've got the
ability that's really good money at
fifty dollars an hour and we could we
could knock out some debt really really
fast I know 36 000 seems like a tower to
you and I love to use those words but
the more income you can generate
that Tower gets short pretty quick
thirty six thousand dollars uh my friend
if you were to and I know you can't do
this every month but if you were to make
an extra six grand a month that's six
months so you you need to start to go
okay what else can I do you might be
able to do some security
um some overnight security four nights
in a in a month on a weekend or so I
don't know I would be doing anything and
everything and then forget just the
police work or police related work what
other work can you do you got some
handyman skills you have got to get
really really intense about this and if
you do it and let's say you come up with
an extra we know you got the six that's
new income if I'd like to see you get to
15 to 20 and new income over the next
several months additional income uh my
friend it is gonna change your life it's
gonna change your world yeah I mean
unbelievable how you can walk through
this and your wife too you know you guys
yeah she needs to get something going on
too she's watching the kids during the
daytime maybe during the afternoon she's
doing this is there something she can do
that's work from home you know that
she's able to pick up nights or at nap
time you know what I'm saying there's
where there's a will there's a way and
the way the internet is these days yeah
we should be committing to 20 hours a
week and let's say she can make
somewhere between let's shoot for 15
bucks an hour I'm just throwing some
numbers out to begin for you guys to go
wait a second because there's something
powerful about writing numbers down on
paper and looking at them and going well
if I do this and she does this
oh my gosh we're out of debt in a year
yep that's right and I think that's
doable do you think that's too too bold
if you can a year to year and a half you
know you can live on 47k if you were to
double your income by her getting a job
and you doing extra hours you're out in
a year I agree it's doable it's doable
we believe in you Talent thank you so
much for the call and thank you for
thank you for how you serve your local
community you guys got this we believe
in you all right don't move on the other
side of the break more Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
foreign
show continues from our Ramsey Solutions
headquarters just south of Nashville
thrilled to have you with us AAA
825-5225 is the toll-free number to jump
in on the conversation as we talk about
your life your money your work and your
relationships I'm Ken Coleman Jade
warshaw is with me this hour We're
thrilled that you are with us uh wow you
know every time I see this I never get
over it I hope I never get over it I
hope you punch me in the throat if I get
over it it's so cool to be able to talk
to people from around the world almost
definitely yeah the world has changed
and you know it's flat when it comes to
this kind of thing the podcast and
YouTube people watching everywhere it's
not actually quack
it's not actually flat it's flat
metaphorically got you see okay relax in
there they thought I was taking a
position well first you hit me with the
toll-free number then you went to the
world as flat Theory so it took me a
minute I get it I know I'm throwing a
lot at you I'm metaphorically because
Shane is on the line yeah and and I'm
good I'm gonna try to say this because I
like to try Harare
Zimbabwe you got it did I get that right
Chris is that you got amazing I'm taking
the rest of the day off uh all right
Shane how can we help sir
well uh I'm getting ready to retire in
about uh four years okay and I'm kind of
concerned what are you concerned about
well
um
we're debt-free we've been debt free for
probably about uh 15 years
uh we've got oh probably close to
we're getting close to a million dollars
in uh our tsps our
401ks traditionals our Roth IRAs our
our other Investments we have
but we have no house
what are you doing in Harare Zimbabwe
I work for the U.S government okay and
so you have government housing
yes okay okay so you got about a million
in your retirement oh go ahead
yeah so uh
in about four years I'm gonna have to
find a place to live and I'm I'm
concerned whether uh
if if I take and pay cash for a house it
takes and wipes out uh you know half of
uh what we have
okay
um how old are you uh and then I'm I'm
61. okay
um
yeah having a paid for home is is part
of what we teach it's important to have
that obviously you want something you
don't want to be renting going into
retirement because it's such a variable
thing with the money that you have I
really don't think that you need to rent
uh when you come back stateside where do
you plan on living like where
where's home going to be
right now it's looking like Houston
Texas okay and have you started looking
at what it would cost to buy a modest
home it's you and your wife in Houston
Texas
yes uh it's uh
around four hundred thousand dollars or
so okay
so
there's a couple of ways you could
approach this
um
well let me let me let me could I ask a
couple questions sure I'm I'm curious uh
two questions
Shane number one what will your
government retirement pension or
benefits what will that look like
uh attention it will be uh three to four
thousand dollars a month okay and and
then and that's until and then you got
Social Security down the line correct
yes and that could be another uh you
know I I don't know I'm I'm thinking
it's like three thousand dollars a month
or something like that okay but the
reason why why I interrupted you Jade
because I want I want us to be all
working from the same page I mean Shane
uh let's just say it's three and let's
say it's three and three that's six
grand a month and my guess is you can
live pretty comfortably on six grand a
month yes yeah
yeah
Shane
I I don't know uh I I would suspect so I
mean do you know debt
say again do you budget now
no we don't unfortunately all right I'm
setting Jade up here but but I'm trying
to also get a real picture where you're
at because you you're presenting you
present really scared and you got four
more years of income first of all then
we've got we know we've got some
benefits coming your way so you're not
operating under I'm gonna retire and all
of a sudden I'm gonna have half of my
retirement there's a whole lot more
money coming in and you're still going
to be 65 and if you had to work some
there's that option too so you still
have four years before this all takes
place so where my brain is going is how
much how much money can you pull
together in the next four years to put
towards a home that's my first thought
um and then my next thought is just
because can we enter into retirement age
doesn't mean that we stop working
completely and we never do anything
again so part of me is like okay what
else can what else would you like to do
once you come back stateside what's
another way that you'd like to earn some
money to put towards this because I'll
be honest I don't love the idea of
saying I'm gonna to pull out a you know
300 000 from my you know I agree and get
hit with that the taxes so I can pay
cash for a home so I think that you've
got four years to save up yeah and then
I think that there's a a home that you
can buy that's you know not overly
expensive and I think you've got some
more working years in you to put to make
Headway on that and I think in the
meantime you're still stacking up money
because here's the thing you've got a
million dollars now in seven years
that's gonna double you know as a lump
sum so you're gonna be okay retirement
wise you know let's dive into these
numbers a little more if you don't mind
um
what's your salary right now
uh my wife and I together we make
probably about a hundred and eighty
thousand dollars
Shane I know what's going on there's no
budget you have no budget so you have no
idea what your money situation is and
you're also a guy who is scared to death
because you're not sure what the future
looks like you haven't run any of these
numbers so 180k combined income in
Zimbabwe
and you got government housing uh can
you live around 80 000 on a four hundred
thousand dollar house he can easily over
the next four years save up most of that
just by scrimping Shane am I right tell
me I'm wrong oh I'm you're not wrong at
least 50 percent no excuse not have 50
down payment no excuse Corey has a 200
000 mortgage am I making this stuff no
that feels right what I mean Shane you
tell us are we are we tripping are you
doing okay in Zimbabwe
What expenses do you have he's debt free
I know that's what I'm saying what are
his other expenses he has no housing hit
let us know Shane
food fuel
you're not spending two dollars just
kidding I mean bro you got more money
than you know what to do with are you a
saver
I and my wife calls me uh Mr Cheap pants
all right that's cheap pants okay now we
know what's going on so you how much
money do you have in savings outside of
the retirement
in cash probably about uh 60 or 70 000.
Shane come on that's great you're fine
you got to stop worrying man and just
put all this intense worrying into
intentionality of saving for that down
payment you're gonna buy a home in cash
and it's going to be completely through
your income you're not gonna have to
touch your retirement at all you guys
are gonna put away a hundred thousand
dollars a year for the next four years
Shane's house in Houston and having a
party because Shane's gonna have money
buried in the backyard okay Shane I get
it now you're you're cheapy cheap pants
or whatever your wife calls you I get it
you're scared there's no reason to be
scared do you give a lot to Shane do you
give a lot
yeah we probably give about uh twenty
thousand dollars a year to our church so
we're fine uh you know 10 yeah okay
you're gonna be just fine hey let me let
me go back and re-ask the question and
answer it for Shane yeah Shane can you
live off of six thousand dollars a month
you should have been like uh yeah I can
live off at two I can hear your wife in
the background going oh no don't tell me
you can live off a two because cheapy
cheaperson or whatever she was calling
it right well emerge she doesn't want
that he's already there he walks around
with a cape hey Shane you're gonna be
fine my friend
I've talked to her about eating beans
and rice and rice and beans and she just
kind of gives me that look you know you
don't need to eat rice beans and beans
and rice like you need to be living it
up in Zimbabwe look
I mean that money goes a long way over
there the storm is over now you don't
have to keep doing that I love when you
sing just out of nowhere it's very
exciting I love that oh
he's like the dude is going to have over
a million dollars oh he could easily
live off of his benefits plus Social
Security they paid for a 400 000 house
Shane go buy your your wife something
nice she's been having her eye on and
just relax take a couple deep breaths
and get on a budget you're gonna feel
better about it this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
what's up guys it's Jade if you show and
one
newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsay show it's
where we help you win in life
specifically with your money your work
and your relationships I'm Ken Coleman
Jade warshaw is with me this hour triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the toll-free number to jump in
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we've had a great time so far we're
thrilled that you're with us if you're
brand new to the program whether you're
watching on YouTube listening uh on
podcast Radio SiriusXM you are in a safe
place we want to help you win cultures
told you you can't and we believe
otherwise so here we go let's go to
Brooklyn in Spokane Washington uh the
the home of my of my esteemed co-host
that's right is that right that's where
I was born how long were you in Spokane
uh till two years old two years okay
very good all right Katie actually
Cheney oh Genie okay very good Brooklyn
how can we help
hi um I'm really happy I'm talking to
you guys specifically because I think
Jade is very inspirational with her
story with her husband and Ken you
always just seem like so nice and
friendly so
I'll take nice you got inspiring that's
very good that's great thank you
Brooklyn yeah how can we help
um so I have two little girls I have a I
was holding a one and a half year old
and I'm trying to do
um I'm on baby step two I did have to
dip into my emergency fund for a tire on
my car but I'm I'm getting that back up
with this paycheck I just got on the
20th which was yesterday so we're good
everything's okay great
um I don't feel like I'm doing gazelle
intensity I feel like I'm more of like a
water buffalo
I'm just doing my best but
um I guess to sum up my debt I have 5
000 in medical uh 5 000 in student loans
which I did pay on
um I am back on that again uh nine nine
thousand and I've been yeah I've been
listening to you about the student loans
and so I made sure to check and see
where I was at
um good and then nine nine thousand in
credit cards I have no car payment
um my dad is a big Dave Dave Ramsey guy
and so he ended up getting me a car
last year that's great what a good dad
shout out for a great dad that's awesome
Brooklyn that's amazing
yeah because he saw that like I
was when I was about to call him
maternity leave because I didn't want
the car payment and I was gonna buy
something cheap and you know just um do
my best but he bought me a new car and
so way to go Dad
um yeah it's a great car all I had to do
is replace a tire and and the windshield
um but my insurance cover the windshield
so that was good and and everything
um but I'm working a lot uh well like as
much as I can but I don't feel like it's
enough what are you doing
um I'm a barista what do you mean a
couple days a week
um I make I only make 25 000 a year and
my debt is at about 20 000 a year sure
and so I guess I'm just a little
intimidated
um by that number first of all let's
just pause
it there you go so so how old is your
child
um I have a seven-year-old so she just
started second grade
um and then I have a one and a half year
old okay and I only have child care for
her two days a week
unless her dad's off on the weekends
then right and so that's watch her and
is that why your hours are limited I'm
trying to dig in here so we know what
we're working with that's the only
reason they're limited is because of my
one and a half year old and where are
you living
um I actually live in Coeur d'Alene
Idaho and I drive 30 minutes to Spokane
to work but I've been working in Spokane
for about six years because the wages
are doubled than what they are in Idaho
right good
so we have an income problem
not just the debt problem and you're
doing this on your own
and that's hard and can I just say
before we get to the money stuff I want
Jay to walk you through that but I just
want you to hear me say that you're
enough you're doing good enough as a mom
you're doing good enough because I just
don't feel that way I could tell and I
want you to stop beating up on yourself
you're doing way better than you think
you are you're feeding these kids you're
clothing these kids you're taking care
of these kids y'all are eating yeah the
lights are on yes okay oh they're always
eating yeah I know that's right isn't
that the truth so hey let's start there
yeah okay so okay um one thing I want to
say very quickly and I want Jay to walk
you through because we've got to get
more income in order to get out of this
debt so what we got to figure out do I
also do
um I also do instacart good um well my
well my seven-year-old is in school
um with my one one and a half year old
but
um
it's not great yeah so so why but I was
kind of seem to get get
some some stuff that ends up taking a
lot longer and then by the time I get
two orders done it's time for my one and
a half year olds to take a nap yeah and
so we gotta go home or let's try to find
something that's let's try to find
something that's maybe online that you
can do some work from home maybe okay
let's look into that because that's
going to allow you to utilize your
evenings possibly once the kids go to
bed that's going to allow you to utilize
the time when your one and a half year
old is napping I would look into some
things like that I know there's work
from home customer service call center
type jobs that you can get into that
have decent hourly rates that's right so
I would check into that
um because for right now just five
hundred dollars is going to change your
world 500 a month is gonna change your
world and I would also well and I also I
also do clean an office on Sundays so
all together I have three three things
I'm I'm doing yes but um but it's only
about 25 000 a year and that's that's
poverty level stuff and so your word I
know no but you're but it's a but listen
it's because I don't think that you've
seen other opportunities and see what
you can do so a couple things
um at the end of the call Christian I
want to make sure we get her we have an
article Ramsey Solutions uh that I wrote
that's up there and it's a it's it's
about all these work from home jobs
you've got to know what's out there
number one but number two okay you've
also got to look at changing this
daycare situation yeah daycare is
crushing you financially and let me tell
you what my wife and I did I just want
to give you an idea and then I want Jade
to jump in you've got to try to find an
old girl you know I say old you'll find
a grandmother who's retired doesn't need
to work but wants to be active and loves
kiddos maybe through your church some
relationships and let's see if we can
cut our expenses on the daycare because
if you've got a grandmother who'd love
to take care of kiddos and could do some
meal prep some light cleaning and it
could be way less money than you're
paying in daycare I just want to mention
that really quick you know and I know
this is going to sound a little bit like
oh but this is a job I have you can make
more doing something other than being a
barista you can make more cleaning
houses that's exactly right and you can
do it on your schedule you know you
mentioned that you've got the you know
it's the limited daycare I just want to
encourage you to use your talents what
you're good at doing to earn more money
at an hourly rate and there's so much
out there I mean literally you can chart
you know get you three two homes a day
and charge 200 each super quick I want
to put out a call to our audience if
you're in the Spokane area
and you know somebody who's got who
needs someone like Brooklyn who can come
in and do the job would you contact our
show contact Ramsay care yep let's see
if we can help Brooklyn Christian make
sure we get her information let's let's
audience can do something special Let's
help this single mom find a great job
opportunity she can make some money we
can do that we can do this this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw is with me this
hour We're thrilled that you are here
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to Brian who
is calling right here from our backyard
Nashville Tennessee Brian how can we
help
hey Kenny Jade how are you it's great
how are you today
doing fairly well so good situation I
lost my job a few weeks ago
fortunately I'm on a severance so it's
going to last a few months okay
um but um
I don't really have any debt except for
my home and I have a second home as well
so about 320 000 left on my personal
home
um my second home which my in-laws live
in uh have about 170 left on that are
they paying you a rent on that
they currently are not no okay so
they're just in there for free about I
bought it about 13 months ago okay
um yeah they're living their rent-free
right at the spotlight that wasn't the
original plan but unfortunately there's
some some decisions that they made
that's where we're at at this point so I
with my prior salary I would I was able
to cover both mortgages no problem okay
but uh with the current situation of
losing my job
um I'll have about till Christmas until
and I've informed them of that I have
about till Christmas and and something's
going to have to change what kind of
work were you doing
uh I was in retail I was an executive in
retail
so what were you learning
uh my base salary was 200 000. that's a
big loss okay and what about your wife
she's School teachers makes 50. okay 50.
so okay so you're feeling it right now
um I I have a couple of questions with
the the home number two with the in-law
staying there can you explain to me why
they're
what what happened to where they were
supposed to pay rent and now they're
they're not
yeah it's interesting
um and the market was really hot last
year and
and they're they were in a situation
with their health they needed to get to
a one level place they lived in a very
large home
um and um
the I was able to I had the money to
make the down payment and they were
going to sell their home while the
market was hot and they
I'm trying to be quick here they they
overpriced their home okay and they
never sold it and it's still on the
market so and and well it's
it's going back on the market but in the
last few months it's not been on the
market they've been trying to sell it
themselves so
um do they have any money or do they
have any money like do are they correct
do you have income no
they uh and they they're both retired
they're one has a part-time job
basically
um they're 11 paycheck to paycheck
do they have debt
oh yes they have over 100 Grand in
credit card debt okay that's the reason
why I had to purchase the house let's go
well you didn't have to but uh I know
the situation I've married a long time
so uh are you and your wife having an
honest come to Jesus meeting with uh
with the in-laws about they need to get
a real realtor uh we've got some
wonderful wonderful people connected uh
real estate professionals if you go to
our Ramsey trusted section of
ramseysolutions.com in their area get a
good realtor price that thing to sell
they don't get to be choosy right now
they need to move this house and move it
now well what are you paying what are
you paying a month for house number two
uh 1270.
I I I just want to know has there been a
come to Jesus meeting or is there going
to be one oh yeah and do they understand
that are they going to do something
about it
um they do I think they're trying to
come to terms with it I'm giving them um
a little breeding room but we'll be back
together okay I just want to make sure
okay because to me that's a big part of
this deal they got to take care of them
right now because you you got to take
care of you yeah um how much is the
severance
um was it'll last till Christmas yeah
basically yeah okay so Ken's going to
help you with the career part of this
um
the good thing is you don't have any
other debt the bad news is this second
house you gotta get out of you got to
get out of this situation with the
in-laws and you've got to set clear time
limits on this and this is one of those
things it it's a deal it's a bad deal
gone bad you know what I'm saying and
now you're kind of in that bed you're
having to lay in it and it's going to
require a lot of awkward conversations
it's going to require weird time limits
where it's like hey especially even
before you had your job I would lost
your job I would have said this but now
that you've lost that job temporarily
it's like all right we've got to get out
of this situation because this is going
to bleed you if you don't can yeah the
work thing I don't think you need a lot
of advice from me I'll jump into that in
a second I'm gonna tell you what I would
do if I were you uh the in-laws would
they're going to be out and out soon if
they need to live with you for a while
for happy wife happy life until they
sell the house that's fine they need to
be out of the second home the reason is
is you have no debt except for the
second home if I remember correctly is
that right
no no I I still have 320 left on my
personal okay and that's that's okay
that's okay but my point is you need
renters Jade he needs renters in the
second home until he decides because now
he's going to take a bath if he tries to
sell it so I want renters in the second
home that's the first thing that was
going to be my that was going to be my
question is because they made a comment
as to they'll just go back to their
previous house
[Music]
yeah if they go back to their house fine
my point is it's not up for you it's
like they're adults they need to get out
of your house that's why I'm saying it's
his call is you have the ability it's
not that's why I said it's awkward you
have the ability to say guys
this is the situation I can't keep
having you rent for free you've got a
place that you own let's set it up to
where you're not having to do the stairs
or blah let's set it up to where you can
move back in because I've got to get
money coming in I lost my income and
I've got to take care of my family and
that's a hard conversation
but yeah I mean I would not draw if it's
me Jade I would not draw this thing out
until December because that's it's no
that's a long time you need a job and
you need to be hustling with everything
you got don't rely on the severance I
would act like the severance doesn't
exist you've got a lot of experience and
skill set uh in your role you don't have
to stay in retail one of the pieces of
advice I give folks like you who've been
in retail for a long time and at a high
level you feel as though you're not
worthy you're not valuable outside of
retail that's not true the fact of the
matter is you're an executive with
executive experience and skill set so
you get after it uh sorry for the
confusion when I say it's not your call
it's just the word I'm using my point is
where they go that's that that's you you
have one concern and one concern only
you got put into a situation or you
allowed yourself to be put in a
situation where you bought a second home
for your in-laws no you need renters
until you can get out of that home
because as soon as you wouldn't take the
capital gains tax if you can keep this
thing afloat for two years then sell the
house I would do it but that is the same
level of intensity as getting Realtors
uh renters as the same level intensity
of getting a job and and Mom and Dad on
the in-law side that's they're grown
they're grown men and women yeah they
gotta your wife's got to support you
there and if they go back to their house
or they go somewhere else I don't care
where they go they just got to get out
and I think Jade's right I wouldn't wait
till December because that's putting a
lot of pressure on you financially
yeah this this Severance is supposed to
be to help float your family yeah not
keep them keep them afloat you see what
I'm saying
yeah it's tough here's the deal I'm
gonna give you a couple resources I'm
gonna give you the get clear assessment
it'd be good for you to take because let
me tell you what I know Brian
that when someone is laid off or fired
is the same traumatic experience as
losing a loved one and you've been
successful at a high level for a long
time and you're rocked a little bit and
that's normal I want you to take the
assessment use it as a self-awareness
tool I'm going to give you the book from
paycheck to purpose I'm going to give
you the book The Proximity principle
everything about connecting everything
about forging A New Path based on
awareness those three resources my gift
to you
please please sit down with your wife
come up with a plan for the in-laws and
you have got to move forward don't rely
on the severance at all act like the
severance is not that's right there
that's the only way to recover from
something like this still a good job
market certainly in Nashville go get
hired Brian and kick the in-laws out
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw joins me the phone
number for you to jump in as we talk
about your life specifically your money
your work and your relationships the
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five hey we are growing
we're going on all platforms and that is
because of you fine folks and so if this
show is helping you in any way would you
help us grow by simply sharing the show
subscribing on the platform that you are
engaged with and and uh and giving us a
positive review that would all help us
you know they say on the old algorithms
so there you go we would appreciate that
very much uh real quick before we get
back to the phones Jade
uh our fearless leader James Childs uh
came in during the break and a couple
days ago you and I were on the program
together and we shared some awesome
testimonials from our audience uh as to
what side hustles they are using to get
ahead in the baby steps whether it's
that very first one thousand dollars and
maybe step one or maybe it's the debt
snowball the smallest debt to the
largest debts or maybe it's uh filling
up that three to six month emergency
fund maybe it's College whatever it is
uh and we said you know what share some
more if you're listening to us watching
us share some more of your stories so
we've got a few here so this is kind of
fun this is cool Michael Finnegan uh
says my side hustle is reffing soccer
I've made about 7 500 so far from
reffing I could make over 10K if I did
it more but I'm trying to balance
spending time with my wife and three
kids I get that that by the way is on
top of his main job where he's working
about 50 hours a week wow but he has an
hour drive each way oh so uh he's
Michael's getting after it man he's
getting in shape too financially and
physically I'm doing soccer I love that
okay I love this one at MW Mir she says
Jade warshaw Ken Coleman I am totally
debt free still working and I have a
side hustle it pays ten dollars an hour
and I work one day a week the side
hustle allows me to play golf for free I
love that which saves me 250 to 300
bucks a month basically I get paid to
play golf living and giving because I
follow the baby steps now that right
there Ken that's that's a I like that
she's just like hey it's a trade yeah I
do this and I get to play golf for free
well we have a theme going here Dana
rudeman says I bartend serve at two golf
courses is my side hustle I make 1500 to
2 Grand a month extra
and I get free golf I love it we got a
theme Here free golf I gotta figure out
how to get free golf down at the old
Legends all you got to do is bartend
apparently that's great at morollo 10
20. hey guys I made 250 for a three day
Board of a dog in my home we talked
about that that's crazy I said I was
willing to board dogs yeah look every I
know people every day who are looking
for someone to watch their dog she did
it over Labor Day weekend it was super
easy and lots of fun she said it's the
best side hustle option for me in my
opinion and let's shout out for all the
stay-at-home mamas out there this uh
lady says that she does doordash uh
while my kids are in school and make
about sixty dollars a day with a
completely free schedule and no boss
four hours mostly driving sitting around
and waiting so there you go wow how
about that look and here's here's what I
want to call out with this side hustle
thing most of us have an hour here an
hour there if you have time to watch
Netflix you have time to get a side
hustle let me just say it like that
why'd you have to go and do that I'm
just saying making us all feel guilty
for sitting there and watching something
I'm just saying do something during that
time I have a buddy that I follow online
and she does the surveys oh you know you
can do the surveys and it's like there
there is always something you can do to
make money even if it's a little bit
there's always something you can do with
that extra 30 minutes here in 14 minutes
there because I got an opinion to do the
surveys yeah I just need to sit at home
and do surveys what's Dad doing oh he's
out there on the patio surveying stuff
[Laughter]
for a little fun your favorite guilty
pleasure on Netflix right now oh right
now I'm watching Suits oh it's great for
the second time I've watched it once oh
and now I'm watching it again dipping
it's a good show it's a good show I
don't know if it's worth it right now
suits you're watching it too but for the
first time I got one more season that's
good it is a fantastic show really good
writing my husband's watching
quarterback he likes out I've already
seen that yeah those kind of short
documentaries I pound those did you
watch the american what is it
um American Gladiators thank you
American Gladiators no I always I was
always irritated by those guys with the
long hair and the extra muscles and the
spandex it was fascinating much for me
it was fascinating okay good let's go to
will who joins us now in Los Angeles
California will how can we help
hey guys how are you good what's up
yeah so uh well the reason I'm calling
uh of course I'm in uh I mean quite some
Dead uh about 30 about 33 000 it's
mostly Consumer Debt
um and I was looking into what that
resolution program but you know just
kind of get that feeling that might not
be the best option so I just wanted to
get like an opinion from of course like
professionals I love gut feelings uh
when you have a gut feeling it usually
it usually you need usually need to
listen to it yeah um so let's go down
that road how much what's your income
uh so right now
um I make somewhere between 55 and 60
000. so let's say 60. yeah kind of kind
of varies but yeah and is it just you or
is their wife kids anything like that
I'm sorry uh is it just you or do you
have a wife or kids oh no yeah I'm
married yeah I have a wife and three
daughters okay and is that income just
yours or does your wife work as well or
is that at all included
so that one is just mine my wife does
work as well
um but you know she probably probably
about half that maybe okay so she's
bringing in about 30. so all in you guys
are have about 90 000 a year
yeah okay here's what I'm looking at and
this is just Baseline I'm like ninety
thousand dollars a year thirty three
thousand dollars of debt now you live in
Los Angeles that's the only thing that
I'm like okay cost of living is pretty
high when you do your when you do your
budget every month or do you do a budget
we just started okay uh this month so we
just started doing a budget yeah that's
I guess part of the reason why I'm in
the situation I'm in so as you've done
your budget when you like after all the
expenses are paid all the minimum
payments are paid on the debt what's
left
um
not a whole lot to be honest
um maybe
maybe a little less than a thousand okay
so you got let's say 900 bucks
that money is the money that you're
going extra and above to pay off this
debt so it's 33 000 of various debts
you're gonna list them from smallest to
largest what's the smallest debt you
have
so the smallest one is uh three thousand
dollars okay so if you were to pick up
some extra work your wife were to pick
up some some extra work as it is you can
pay that thing off in three months but I
want to go faster than that yeah yeah so
do you see where I'm getting at here
whatever debt resolution company they
were going to charge something and we
don't want to give any more money away
this is debt we can pay off ourselves
right yeah so that gut feeling I think I
think you were right I think you looked
at that and said why you know why am I
going to pay somebody to settle
something I can call them up myself why
am I going to pay somebody to lump it
all together
I don't want to lump it all together I
want to feel these small wins right
it'll feel great when you knock out that
three thousand dollar debt
yeah so that that's my advice I'm
listing these I'm doing a debt snowball
you and your wife
um I'm guessing she's part-time because
she's staying home with kids
uh yeah she only works about maybe like
four or five hours a day
um she's a nanny so it's really just
kind of uh picking up the kid from from
his school staying with him for a little
bit until his parents come home that's
pretty much it so it's just a couple
hours a day okay I love that I would
love for her to Nanny for a family of
three
and do that same thing and make triple
the amount yeah right you know what I'm
saying so these are the things this is
the way I want you thinking because with
your income you guys can definitely get
this done uh the average let's see
you're in I don't want to say this
because you're in Los Angeles but the
the median income is around 67 000. so
if I said to you hey live on 67 000 and
put their rest towards debt
you should be able to do that now and
where you're at it might be tougher so
for you then that might be my like hey
I've got to get do these side hustles
that Ken and I have been talking about
but either way I'm not doing the debt
resolution program yeah I agree
completely okay got it yeah yeah um I
was I was discussing it with my wife
um I I used to do security before I'm in
a different position right now
um that's always been in the back of my
mind is maybe just kind of Moonlighting
go do it again so all right yeah that's
it yeah that's what that's what what
came to mind yesterday when we spoke to
the people from from that program I
haven't signed up or anything but good
sign up yeah I figured that would be a
better route to go yeah I love it you
can hear the excitement in his voice
he's ready he knows that this is gonna
be the thing that moves the dial
short-term sacrifice for a long-term
game it's always going to be worth it
she is Jade warshaw I'm Ken Coleman this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show so glad
you are with us as we talk with you
about your life I'm Ken Coleman Jade
warshaw is with me this hour triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the phone number our scripture of the
day comes from First Corinthians 9 verse
24. do you not know that in a race all
the runners run but only one gets the
prize run in such a way as to get the
prize and our quote from Mrs Spanx
herself Sarah Blakely
you know I've had that pleasure thanks
yeah I've interviewed her twice she's uh
she's really really interesting lady I
love that is she the one that goes on
Shark Tank yeah uh yeah but she's been
on there but she's the founder of spank
yes very cool very cool yeah uh her
quote is don't be intimidated by what
you don't know that can be your greatest
strength and ensure that you do things
differently from everyone else that is
good I like that Mike dropped there all
right to the Big Apple we go New York
City Sarah is there Sarah how can we
help
hi thank you for taking my call you bet
so my question is um should I move to a
job that pays more but has worse
benefits
um I have my current job has really good
health insurance good Medic or good
medical insurance has a it has a pension
um but it pays pretty low over the past
year the reason I moved to that job was
because we ended up needing to do IVF
which the total for that came to about a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars
which it covered in full wow so yeah so
um and I am pregnant now yeah
congratulations
that's awesome Sarah my wife and I went
through that and it did not work for us
but God had a different plan and it
turned out great I'm going to tell you
something right now
um you should never make a fine a
professional decision on medical
benefits alone
not not so it's not enough so I've got
to ask now that I've said that the
opportunity you have before you how much
of a pay bump is it
so it's I actually switched from this
job because I moved it was two reasons I
moved and I knew I was going to need IVF
so the job that I had before that I
still worked per diem for and have the
opportunity to go back to meet 110 000 a
year
um the job that I switched to initially
I made 69 000 and I'm now up to 82 000.
okay so 110 versus 82. yeah okay and the
benefits aren't as good uh well I mean
what are they when you compare them you
know Apple's apples how I mean how bad
is it in the in the in the new
opportunity where you were before it's
so confusing I'm so confused but I do
understand what you're saying let's just
call it the new job okay
so the the pay difference is
every year I did not get a raise at the
other place at all
um I have the good health insurance I
have a pension
um at the current job yeah all right
what about the work itself
I mean which one of you gives you a
ladder to to more growth you're saying
you're not opt you don't have an option
for an annual raise of at least three
percent which is very standard by the
way you don't have that at the new job
at the new job that's where I do get a
raise the new job I have all these
really good benefits with the lower pay
no no no see that's where we get
confused you've got an opportunity to go
back to where you were but I'm calling
that the new job where you are you're
making 82k and you got great benefits
and you get a three percent pump I'm
saying the job that will pay you more
110. are you saying there's no option
for raises
um
very little option for raises so what
they do is they started me when I was
there at 90 000 and they increase your
pay based off
um I'm a physician assistant so it's
based off how many patients I can see
once you Max that out you kind of max
out your salary
so occasionally they might throw
something in maybe they would be nice
into a cost of living reason but I never
saw that they okay and so you're telling
me based on the amount of patience you
could see you would be maxed at 110.
yeah and how different are the benefits
that's what I'm trying to get at is it
that big of a deal is it going to cost
you more
um so the benefit I mean the higher
paying job that I came from had no IVF
coverage they covered zero percent are
you planning on doing IVF again yeah
hmm yeah okay well then that changes
everything we could have started and
finished there if you believe you're
going to have to do IVF and you know
your medical situation and your current
company does full coverage of that then
I think that's a no-brainer and
that's you know idea
yeah it's not like this is the only job
opportunity you'll ever have you're a
physician's assistant the sky's the
limit for you in fact you should be as a
as a PA you should have the opportunity
for continual growth so the fact that
you would be sort of capped at this
other place to me it's not the best
option moving forward anyway yeah I
agree so if if IVF
is something we think we have to lean on
I'd stay where you are you're getting
you're getting a three percent bump you
got good benefits yeah I think if I'm
you based on what you've told me I want
I want I want Jade to weigh in but I
would stay where I am now just for now
temporary yeah I'd stay put knowing what
your goals are because your goals right
now are the IVF it's going to be covered
you know that you have the potential to
earn more money and for me that matters
most like no I want to know that I have
potential don't cut I don't want to be a
glass ceiling you know what I'm saying
so that for me for me the choice is
simple and like Ken said and like I said
this is not forever you can reevaluate
in five years you can reevaluate in two
years that's right you know um this is
for right now and then after you have
your next round of you know you have
this baby then you have your next round
of IVF have your next baby then you can
talk about this again and decide what
you want to do yeah I like the fact that
that massively important procedure which
just brought you a baby uh is covered
that's a huge benefit I think yeah I
think it's a no-brainer you gotta choose
your heart here and uh your career
growth is down the line with with uh
quickly with a pension versus a 401k
yeah I mean I can put money into a 403 b
which I've been doing because I believe
I can take that with me yeah up then
um if I'm there for five years I will
get what I what was promised
um which will be small or minimal but if
you stay for 30 30 years then it's a
good pension you're not making a 30-year
decision here no you and I both know
Jade knows if IVF works and baby 2 is on
the way or if it doesn't work either one
of those scenarios you're not staying
where you are for a long term isn't that
true
well I guess
your heart's saying your heart saying
Ken that's true your head's going slow
down this killing guy is pushing you a
little bit I love a 403 b option a
little bit better anyway because you
have more control of what it's invested
in yeah that's right so if if it really
was boiled down to that if somebody said
Jade should I choose be 2401k or a pinch
and I'm going 401K all day and don't
stay at a job just because of a 30-year
pension yeah yeah that's a recipe for
accepting average and complacency yeah
as opposed to get out get it you know
that's where Jay and I are coming from
we we love
um being able to set our own pace set
our goals and get after it don't don't
let me tell you something she's a former
D1 athlete get out of her way you try to
tell her what she can't do and hold her
back from progress watch out dunking on
folks you're gonna need more knee pads I
promise you that right now and I'm the
same way you are the same way and so
that's why we're giving you this advice
Sarah a baby first family first and then
dream next yes but no limits on the
dream no limits that's right the the the
whole idea of saving for retirement
you're going to be able to do that
regardless right 15 into your 401k or
403 b and even if you did have a pension
that wouldn't count for the whole 15
anyway you'd still be investing into
some other vehicle so there you have it
yeah good on you for really thinking
there's three questions that's good very
good you're smart I'm so happy for you
uh you're gonna be a great when's the
baby
um November 22nd but probably much much
earlier oh wow
well we are so excited for you what can
we give her as a baby gift Jade let's
see if you have every dollar
um I don't know let's get him set up
let's get her set up with Financial
Peace University and every dollar that
is our gift to you our baby gift our
baby shower gift I love it way to go
Sarah oh I love I love being involved in
a baby shower that I don't have to
actually show up to that was the best of
both yeah that was great I put all the
pressure on you I just saw those games
what should we give her and you were
like oh yeah that was beautiful I love
it all right fantastic stuff hey love
being with you my friend Jade warshaw
Ken Coleman with you America James
Childs thanks for keeping it all on the
tracks God bless that man and you
America this is the Ramsay show
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsey win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]